des journaux des magazines du vin et de
la charcuterie dans une même boutique
c'est possible et c'est le pari que se
sont lancé hugo roux et son père avec le
sommelier du coin avant de s'implanter
il a fallu étudier le potentiel du
quartier qu'on a vu que 74 % de la
population démordent pas bien souhaité
avoir un caviste barre dans le centre de
mort paille qui est un s'entasser papa
délabrée mais on va dire à partir de 17
heures le soir il n'y a plus personne
car il n'y a que des banques donc nous
notre objectif avec cette étude de
marché c'était prendre le pari de
redynamiser ce centre est de pouvoir
avoir un moment convivial avec les gens
qu'ils puissent venir partager un moment
convivial entre un bon verre de vin une
belle assiette de charcuterie l'équipe
puisse remporter chez eux de bons
souvenirs ils étaient près de 150
amateurs et curieux à l'inauguration de
ce double commerce inédit l'idée aussi
qu'on est ce de type de commerce dont un
nouveau qui n'existaient pas s'en mord
pas et qui est une offre toute
particulière donc qui je l'espère va
voilà aussi avoir un rayonnement au-delà
de maurepas et bénéficier avec le
dynamisme de la presse donc c'est une
bonne idée et c'est aussi un service de
proximité parce que nous avons une
population aussi qu'il ait dit à
maurepas redynamiser le centre ville et
ses commerces une priorité pour la ville
pour mon rôle aussi en tant que maire
avec mon adjointe au commerce c'est de
travailler avec les propriétaires de
voir avec eux quels sont les loyers
qu'ils pourraient faire de négocier
aussi a vécu pour que les loyers souvent
doivent aller à la baisse pour éviter
qu'on ait des banques ou des agences
immobilières encore qui viennent
s'installer en centre-ville amour pas le
taux de vacance est inférieur à 10%
selon la municipalité